this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 20,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill ever since man landed
on the moon we've been dreaming of
colonizing it we have the technology to
get there the only thing that is
standing in our way is the cost of
sending materials to the moon while
companies like SpaceX and Blue Origin
are aiming to reduce the cost of rocket
launches the real challenge will be
using the materials available to us on
the moon
luckily for us the moon has no shortage
of raw materials for us to exploit but
new technologies will need to be
developed in order to extract them
efficiently this would give the lunar
colony the materials necessary to build
and expand but more importantly
stimulate a lunar economy where it can
sell the materials that gathers like
rocket fuel and rare metals so what
materials are available in the lunar
soil the elements available differ with
regions on the moon water will be a
high-priority resource and in 2009
india's chandrayaan-1 lunar satellite
detected ice at the moon's poles the
poles are likely the best candidate for
our first moon colonists but not just
for the water there are regions of the
poles that receive almost continuous
sunlight like the ridges of the
Shackleton crater allowing these early
colonists to bring solar panels with
them and have a continuous supply of
energy an energy will be in high demand
as all extraction techniques will need
to be electrified the most efficient
method of extraction of the lunar ice
will be to simply collect the lunar soil
containing the ice and place it in a
microwave oven where's will evaporate at
very low temperatures thanks to the
vacuum on the moon the vapor will then
be condensed and collected our next
commodity that will be in high demand is
oxygen and surprisingly oxygen is one of
the most abundant elements on the moon
but it is trapped in the form of oxides
like iron oxide aluminium oxide titanium
oxide and silicon oxide these are
valuable materials and if we can create
oxygen as a byproduct of their
extraction that just makes it all the
more worthwhile iron will be a vital
material for any lunar colony here on
earth it is so vital for modern society
that its production and utilization is a
clear indicator of economic growth it
reinforces our buildings through rebar
it holds the weight of our electrical
grid on its shoulders and a bridge is
our oceans and rivers
and it is heavy making it far too
expensive to transport to the moon to
produce iron with current methods we
first need to mine limestone coal and
the iron ore itself the coal is refined
into coke by baking off impurities like
tar and water in a coke oven which
itself is an energy intensive process
this coke is then used as a fuel source
in a blast furnace to reduce our iron
ore by producing carbon monoxide which
reacts with the iron oxide ore to form
iron and carbon dioxide while the
limestone breaks down to carbon dioxide
and calcium oxide which reacts with the
impurities in the ore the pig iron
produced then needs further refinement
in an oxygen furnace to produce steel
this process will need to be streamlined
for Annie lunar colony by shipping heavy
fossil fuels to the moon purely to
extract iron from its ore is simply not
an option to add some incentive to
develop this technology this complete
process contributes 1.7 Giga tons of
carbon dioxide to the atmosphere
annually five percent of total global
emissions developing a fully electrified
version will allow us to manufacture
emissions-free steel NASA offered a
quarter of a million price to the first
research team that could develop a
reasonable method to process these
resources on the moon while producing
oxygen as a by-product Donald Sadoway a
professor of materials chemistry at MIT
proposed using an electrolytic cell this
cell would use an electric current to
separate the metals and release the
oxygen from its bonds aluminium
production already uses electrolysis to
refine aluminium oxide aluminium oxide
has a very high melting point of two
thousand and seventy two degrees Celsius
and so to reduce the energy required the
aluminium oxide is instead dissolved in
molten cryolite which is a lower melting
point of 1012 degrees Celsius and thus
this method reduces energy requirements
substantially this molten mixture is
then placed in a steel case which is
lined with a graphite cathode the anodes
are also made from graphite when an
electric current flows aluminium ions
form at the cathode where they gain
electrons and sink to the bottom to form
molten aluminium that can be
topped off meanwhile the oxygen ions
accumulate at the graphite anodes where
they react with the carbon in the
graphite to form carbon dioxide this
will be the general process for metal
extraction on the moon but graphite is
obviously off the table as the material
for our anode and cathode if we want to
produce oxygen as it produces carbon
dioxide and is consumed in the process
carbon is in short supply on the moon
though so this may be a clever way of
producing carbon dioxide on the moon for
plant growth in a paper published in
2012 Sadoway and his research partner
antoine elinor conclude a chromium alloy
anode is the best choice as a protective
and conductive layer of chromium and
aluminium oxides form on a surface this
allows it to trade electrons with the
negatively charged oxygen ions without
being heavily corroded in the process an
oxygen is formed instead of carbon
dioxide this will be an incredibly
energy intensive process and it's one of
the main stumbling blocks currently
stopping it from being used here on
earth for iron refinement it's one of
the main reasons aluminium is more
expensive than iron generating
electricity on the moon will initially
rely on lightweight solar panels shipped
to the moon but for a moon economy to
grow it will need to be capable of
expanding its own electrical grid
aluminium is readily available on the
moon and it can be used for wiring like
it is here on earth for high-voltage
power lights the primary material used
in solar panels is silicon which is
abundant on the moon and applications go
far beyond just solar panels it can be
used to make glass and excuse to alloy
with aluminium and iron while solar
panels primary material is silicon the
silicon we find in solar panels needs to
be incredibly pure and its production
also requires a carbon supply in the
form of coke or charcoal I couldn't find
any technologies being developed to free
its production from these feedstocks
which are not available on the moon and
ultimately I think sending lightweight
solar panels from the earth to the moon
will probably be more economic until new
technologies are developed the moon has
a rich supply of helium-3 however thanks
to solar winds and if we manage to
develop nuclear fusion technologies
generating power on the moon will become
vastly easier and allow the moon to
develop a healthy economy harvesting
discus and sending it back to earth
ultimately a self-sustaining moon colony
will depend completely on its ability to
harvest and make use of the materials
available to it and thankfully the
technologies being developed for that
purpose have uses here right on earth
for freeing us from dependency on fossil
fuels as always striving to do what is
difficult challenges humans to develop
and grow as a species this is why the
space program is important challenging
ourselves is a core part of being human
it allows us to discover things about
ourselves and learn what we are really
capable of and so it's important for you
to continually challenge yourself by
learning new skills these days you can
teach yourself pretty much any skill
online and Skillshare is a fantastic
place to do it
with professional and understandable
classes that follow a clear learning
curve you can dive in and start learning
how to do the work you love from
creative skills like animation and
illustration that allowed me to grow
this YouTube channel to business courses
like this one that may help you turn
that idea of yours into a high growth
business the Premium Membership begins
around ten dollars a month for unlimited
access to all courses but the first
1,000 people to sign up with this link
will get their first two months for free
so ask yourself right now what skill
have you been putting off learning what
project have you been dreaming of
completing but you aren't sure if you
have the skills to do it why not start
right now and sign up to Skillshare
using the link below to get your first
two months for free you have nothing to
lose and a valuable life skill to gain
as always thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters if
you'd like to see more from me the links
to my Instagram Twitter subreddit and
discord server are below
you